مساء الخير السؤال اللي شغل ناس كثيره في
مصر وخارج مصر من المهتمين بالاستثمار او
بالتعامل المادي والاقتصادي مع مصر هو هل
سعر الدولار يشهد انخفاض زي ما حصل في
الايام القليله الماضيه لما انخفضت قدام
الكينيه حوالي عشرين علشان يسجل سبعطاشر
خمسه وسبعين تقريبا مقارنه بسبعطاشر خمسه
وتسعين منذ عده ايام سيقع على هذا
الانخفاض الحقيقه الاجابه المختصره ان هذا
الانخفاض بيعبر عن اه مرحله مؤقته او ظروف
مؤقته بسبب ظروف واليات العرض والطلب ولا
يعني اذا كنت بدوره على الاجابه مختصره ان
هذا يعبر عن تحسن عام وشامل في الاقتصاد
المصري وفي العوائد الدولاريه يضمن انخفاض
على هذا المستوى لفتره طويله او يضمن
انخفاض مستمر في قيمه الدولار مقابل
الجنيه عشان نفهم المساله ببساطه القصه
انه زي ما اعلان المسؤولين في البنك
المركزي سواء على لسان مصادر معلومه او
مشكله انه اللي حصل انه مصر كانت متاثره
منذ عده شهور وتحديدا من مايو 2018
بالازمه ان اصابت ما يسمى بالاسواق
الناشئه
وما هي الاسواق انشاء بين قوسين هي
الاسواق دول العالم الثالث اللي هي زي مصر
وتركيا وسيريلانكا وبنغلاديش والارجنتين
او الاسواق اللي يسموها الاسواق الناميه
ودي طبعا درجات و تستحقه من مستقبلا حلقه
عن ما يسمى بالاسواق الاشياء لكن في كل
الاحوال كان فيه ازمه في الاسواق الناشئه
ملخص هذه الازمه انه المستثمرين الكبار
اللي هي المؤسسات الكبيره لما بتيجي توجه
اه استثماراتها بتفكر في حين اودى امواله
في الاسواق الناضجه يعني اللي هي البلاد
المستقره في الولايات المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبي واليابان ولا لديها اسواق ناشئه
اللي بيحرقوا في الحالتين هو الربح فاذا
كان الفائده عاليه على الدولار مثلا في
الولايات المتحده هذه الاموال ب تتجه الى
الاسواق الكبيره زي الولايات المتحده اذا
كان الدولار او في الاتحاد الاوروبي اسعار
الفائده منخفضه يفضل ان الاسواق الناشئه
يتعامل معها في العاده من خلال ما يسمى
مؤشرات زي مثلا مؤشر مورجان ستانلي اللي
هي يقول الاسواق الناشئه على بعض هكذا في
مؤشر واحد فهو بيشتري المؤشر يعني يروح
سوق المال
يشتري المؤشر كل عربات يعني بقطع النظر عن
طريقه الشراء لغير المتخصصين لواحد من
حضرتكم مش بيمارس المساله او مش متابعه في
النهايه يعني مصر كانت متاثره
بانصراف الاستثمارات وبالتالي ان خلافات
العوائد الدولاريه عن الاسواق انشاء شانها
شان شانها في ذلك شان الدول في تركيا وزي
اه اندونيسيا وزي الارجنتين الى اخره اللي
حصل انه في يناير الماضي حصل حاجتين
الحاجه الاولانيه انها حصلت زياده مره
اخرى في التدفقات الدولاريه يعني ابتدا
يدخل مصر الدولارات قدرها بعض المسؤولين ب
حوالي واحد ونصف مليار دولار لما بنقول
العراق الدولاريه يعني بنقول من المصادر
المختلفه المصادر المختلفه وسلم انه من
قناه السويس منه من عوائد المصريين اللي
بيبعثوا من الخارج الى اه مصر بس منها من
السياحه مصادر متعدده
لكن المصدر الاكبر ما يسمى
بالاستثمار فى ادوات الدين بين قوسين
بنسميها احيانا الاموال الساخنه وما هي
الاموال الساخنه
بيجي مستثمر عنده دولار اذا كان المستثمر
ده يعني بنك او اذا كان فرد ومع مثلا
مليون دولار وعاوزه يستثمر هم
انا استثمر ونفى اي واحد من ال الجهاد او
من الوسائل الكاذبه لاستثمار اموالهم
عليها عائد كبير انه يقرض الحكومه المصريه
او الحكومه التركيه او يخرج حكومه
الارجنتين
ولما يقر بها ينتظر العائد على مدار ثلاثه
شهور او 6 شهور على حسب ما ال ال البند
اللي بيشتري او السنه اللي يشتريه طيب
الحكومه في مقابل هذا القرض بتقدم له فاذا
الفائده مغريه بالنسبه للمستثمر لان في
بعض الدول بتبقى الفائده مرتفعه والفائده
في مصر مغريه لهذا النوع من المستثمرين
وطبعا فيه كلام كثير يقال على معدل
الفائده لكن ممكن اختص لكم الشديد انه مصر
المعيار ما يسمى بالفائده الحقيقيه يعني
الفائده اللي يديها البنك وقت منها سعر
التضخم هي الثاني اعلى بلد في العالم وفقا
للتقرير اه يعني صدر مؤخرا يعني
الفائده الحقيقه تقريبا اربعه وثمانيه من
عشره في المائه وبالتالي هي مغريه بالنسبه
للمستثمر اللي عاوزه استثمر فلوسي فى
ادوات الدين المصريه ادى الى وجود تدفق
ركعتين التدفق اللي رجعت اني اذا جزء من
يعني تحسن في نظره المستثمر الاجنبي نسبيا
مش بس لمصر ولكن للاسف كان شيء بصفه عامه
ولمصر بصفه خاصه اضف زي ما اقول لحضراتكم
ارتفاع العائد على الاستثمار فى ادوات
الدين المصريه اضف الى كل ده عامل مهم جدا
وهو انه الفتره اللي شهدت هذا التدفق
تزامنت وليس من قبيل المصادفه ان فيه
مجموعه كبيره من التقارير الدوليه اللي
تكلمت بشكل جيد على الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
الان ما يدعم تحسنا وما يشجع المستثمر على
الاقل انه يجي يستثمر في ادوات الدين يعني
مش يستثمر استثمار هو مصنع وبسرعه
مستثمر مباشر ولكن بيجي فى ادوات الدين
يعني اسف الحكومه المصريه بالدولار الايه
ال الحاجات الايجابيه اللي شكلت عنده ثقه
اكثر في الاستثمار المباشر في ان يستثمر
في ادوات الدين عندك ابرز حاجه تقارير
البنك الدولي من حوالي اسبوعين اللي قالت
فيها كلام ايجابي عن الاقتصاد المصري
التقارير اللي صدر بعدها من صندوق النقد
الدولي ثم البيان اللي صدر عنه بيتكلم
بشكل ايجابي عن الاقتصاد المصري اضف الى
كده مجموعه اخرى من المؤشرات المهمه في
ارتفاع عوائد السياحه بالنسبه البيره
ارتفاع عوائد اه او ارتفاع اه ال اه حجم
الانتاج من اه حقول الغاز وده يعني اذا ما
كانت يبيع ويدلوا مباشره عوائد لكن كمان
على الاقل حقيقه اه يمنع الاموال اللي
كانت ب تنفقها مصر على استيراد الغاز اللي
هم كانوا في حدود اثنين ونص مليار دولار
سنويا كلها امور ايجابيه يعني في النهايه
عندهم مؤشرات كثيره الحقيقه لكن مش عاوز
يعني ادخل في تفاصيل كلها امور ايجابيه
تعني انه من المقبول انه الدولار الان
ينخفض المقابل الكريم لو حضرتك متابعين في
ديسمبر الماضي قام البنك المركزي ب خطوه
مهمه جدا وهي انهاء ما يسمى باليه تحويل
الدولار للمستثمر الاجنبي هي الاليه
بدايه من مارس على ما اذكر 2013 كان
المستثمر الاجنبي اللي ما عنده ثقه
يستثمر في ادارات الدين او يستثمر في
المرسله المصريه بس هو مش عاوزه هيدي انه
خير بعدين لما يحب يطلع ما ليش عمله صعبه
متى ما كانش صعبه البنك المركزي عشان يطمن
والله تعالى اهلا وسهلا استثمر لم تتعاون
اننا اه اوفر لك العمله الصعبه في اي وقت
فيه بسعر السوق يعني انها تملك
دولارات قالت دولارات بالسعر اللي يحددوا
السوق وخروج
الناس انها تيجي تستثمر وتسلم الحكومه
المصريه في ديسمبر الماضي البنك المركزي
ال اليدين وكان السبب المعلن وقتها لان
احنا ماحناش محتاجين الى تمر المستثمر
احنا عندنا وفره في الدولار وعندنا الامور
بشكل جيد
بحد ذاته ب اسعار الفائده اللي فيه
وبالتالي احنا مش محتاجين ضمن الحاجه
عندنا كفايه جدا من الدولارات لكن الكلام
المعلم الكلام غير المعلن انه كان واقع
الامر انه اثناء الفتره اللي تعرضت فيها
الاسواق الناشئه
الى انخفاض في شهيه المستثمرين للاستثمار
فيها خرج من مصر
كم كبير جدا من الدولارات اللي هي اللي بت
سمي اللي ما تسمى الاموال الساخنه اللي
كانت حضرتكم عليها لما خرجت الاموال البنك
المركزي الطلب من البنوك انها مول هذه
الاموال لانه هو مش حابب يدفع لهم من عنده
لانه كان محتاجه الدولارات اللي اخذتها من
المستثمرين
لاعتبارات اخرى لزياده مثلا ال ال
الاحتياطي النقدي الاعتبارات خاصه
باحتياجات الخزنه المصريه البنوك مو له
الاموال دي للمستثمرين وهما خارجين من
اموال المودعين في البنوك التي تبقى
مكشوفه فاجات للبنك المركزي الحاله بوش من
الان فصاعدا كل مستثمر عاوز يدخل يدخل
عليكم انتم مباشره وبالتالي يبقى في ضخ
دولارات عليكم وبالتالي مش حيكون فيه
مشكله وال بدا بالفعل المستثمرين بدايه من
يناير الجاري يدخلوا على السوق مباشره ما
يسمى بالانترنت دا معناه ايه معناه انه
لما بيكون فيه تدفق الاموال على مصر يبقى
في وفره من الدولار في الاتفاقيه شويه اذا
حصل خروج زي ما حصل على مدار 7 شهور
السابقه على يناير مايو 2013
ويحصل انه اللي انخفض بشكل كبير او على
حسب الظروف السوق ده معناه انه بدايه من
يناير حاله الانخفاض اللي حصل في الدولار
هو جزء من السياسه الجديده الى المحافظ
الذي ينكرها وقال في حوار ل بلومبرغ من
حوالي اسبوعين ان السوء يبقى فيه نسبه
تقلبات ارتفاعا وانخفاضا بالسبب الغاء
الاليه اللي كانت عمله يعني اه اه اه يعني
استقرار كبير في السوق على مدار الشهور
الماضيه خلاصه الكلام انه السؤال
الانخفاض اللي حصل فيه هو جزء من سياسه
جديده تعني ان
السعر الان وصل الدولار ها يكون فيه
تقلبات
ارتفاعا وانخفاضا
انه فيه مؤشرات ايجابيه تدعم الجلي انه
مؤقتا قدم الدولار لكن لا تدعم ال ال جنيه
قدم الدولار على بصفه دائمه او بشكل كبير
لانه حتى هذه اللحظه التحسن كلها في
قطاعات متقلبه زي مثلا الاموال الساخنه
التي تقرر الحكومه المصريه في قطاع
السياحه
لكن حتى الان ما عندناش مصادر يعني عندنا
الدولارات من مصادر مستقره زي مثلا
الصناعه والزراعه و قطاعات الانتاج
المختلفه اشكركم والى لقاء اخر باذن الله
[موسيقى]